.
* Rasante Musik *
Darf ich auch mal fahren?
Papa macht dann das Männchen.
Rocky, ist schon gut.
Viel Platz für Action und noch
mehr Spass - direkt vor der Haustür.
* Mario lacht und jauchzt. *
* Mario lacht. *
Ein Rowdy.
Ja, wie du.
- Ja ...
Aber wenn man ihnen
immer alles verbietet,
können sie sich
gar nicht richtig entwickeln.
Seit einem Monat
wohnt Familie Tscharner
in ihrem Traumhaus in Sopchoppy.
Die Rheintaler sind
an der Westküste Floridas angekommen.
Wir können es noch nicht glauben.
- Jetzt wohnen wir am Meer.
Mit einem Mobile Home,
ihrem ersten Objekt,
wollen sie
ins Immobilienbusiness einsteigen.
Die Unterlegscheiben dort unten.
Es ist ungewohnt kalt
im Sonnenstaat Florida
und die Heizung ist ausgefallen.
Füllst du ihn mit Petrol?
- Klar, ich fülle den Tank da unten.
Ah, jetzt brennt's.
Auf und davon
in die Einsamkeit Islands.
Hier gibt es Ruhe,
Raum und v.a. viel Platz.
Ein Grundstück
so gross wie 600 Fussballfelder
gehört hier zwei Innerschweizern:
Isabelle und Steff Felix.
Wir haben noch gar nicht
das ganze Grundstück gesehen.
Bald schon sollen hier
Tiny-Häuser für Gäste entstehen.
Dann geht es bis hier.
Hier wäre noch der Pfad.
Es muss erst dann genau sein,
wenn die Fundamente gebaut werden.
Dann muss es wirklich
im Blei sein und stimmen.
Das Baugespann ist erstellt -
auf Isländisch.
Ein Restaurant auf Mallorca.
Otmar hat alles
in diesen Traum investiert.
Mit Gabor, seinem Partner,
gestaltet er das Lokal um.
Hallo.
Zur Unterstützung
reisen Freunde aus der Schweiz an.
Auch die bisherige Besitzerin
des Lokals hilft mit.
Dabei entstehen Missverständnisse.
Die dort vorn nehme ich mit.
- Welche nimmst du mit?
Das habe ich dreimal gesagt:
Sie kommen auf den Balkon.
Wenn man was vorhat,
muss man vorwärtsmachen.
Bald schon ist Eröffnung -
und diese soll gelingen.
Wir geben unser Bestes.
Ich bin sehr offen und lustig.
In der Schweiz
mochten das die Leute sehr.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
# Uf u dervo, yeah.
Auf Island
ist der Spätsommer angebrochen.
Mit der Ruhe ist es nun vorbei.
Aus der Schweiz sind
drei Container angeliefert worden.
Ihr Inhalt:
Bauelemente für drei Tiny-Häuser.
Auch aus der Schweiz angereist
ist Zimmermann Heinz Beer
mit Frau Elisabeth.
So, willkommen.
Velkominn.
- Hallo.
Hallo, seid ihr gut gereist?
- Ja, super, danke.
Bist du seekrank geworden?
- Nein.
Heinz auch nicht?
- Nein, alles wunderbar.
Hallo.- Heinz, freut mich,
dass du gekommen bist.
Ja.
- Jetzt haben wir Manpower.
Hallo, Isabelle.
- Willkommen.
Seid ihr gut gereist?
- Tipptopp, alles hat gut geklappt.
Hallo zusammen.
Beers Mannschaft ist tags zuvor
mit dem Flieger angekommen.
Tschau.
- Hallo.
Seid ihr gut angekommen?
Tipptopp.
Ihr Ziel: In drei Wochen
sollen drei Häuser stehen.
Wochenlang haben Steff und Isabelle
die Fundamente für die Häuser gelegt,
45 m3 Beton verbaut
und Hunderte Meter
Strom- und Wasserleitungen gelegt.
Eine knochenharte Arbeit, selbst
für Steff, den gelernten Steinmetz.
Es war schon anstrengend,
weil der Termin immer näher rückte.
Die Hausbaufirma sollte bald kommen
und ich war noch nicht so weit.
Der Beton sollte eigentlich
drei Wochen lang trocknen.
Eine Woche vor dem Aufbau
mischten wir den letzten Beton.
Es wurde extrem knapp.
Habt ihr noch
keine Sickerleitungen gelegt?
Doch, ich habe eine gelegt.
Sie führt hinters Haus
und durchs ganze Gelände hindurch.
Das ist gut.
Es sieht sehr stabil aus.
Das wird gut.
Nun messen wir alles ein
und bereiten alles vor,
damit wir morgen früh,
wenn der Kran da ist,
die Häuser platzieren können.
Ihre Ferien-Lodge verfügt
bereits über drei kleine Wohnungen.
Eine davon heisst Himinn, der Himmel.
* Lachen *
(Elisabeth) Wow, hübsch.
Hei, ei, ei!
- (Heinz) Toll.
Hoffentlich haben wir etwas Zeit,
um uns drinnen aufzuhalten.
Das liegt an euch.
- Ja.
Das hoffen wir schon.
Also ...
Du kannst das machen.
- (Elisabeth) Ja.
Gut, los geht's.
- Viel Spass.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Es gibt eine Küche,
aber ihr werdet wohl
die meiste Zeit bei uns sein.
Hier ist noch das Badezimmer.
Wunderbar.
Es ist alles da, was man braucht.
Wenn etwas fehlt, meldet euch.
- Vielen Dank.
Mit dem Wasser gibt es
wohl keine Probleme, nicht wahr?
Letztes Jahr
gab es ein Problem mit dem Wasser.
Tatsächlich?
- Ja, der Sommer war zu warm.
Ja.
- Es gab kein Wasser mehr.
Wahrscheinlich müssen wir
noch Bohrungen durchführen
und nach Wasser bohren.
Vielen Dank, Isa.
Mit der Erweiterung ihrer Lodge
werden sie noch mehr Wasser brauchen.
Auf Island ist jeder Hof
selbst dafür verantwortlich.
Eigenständigkeit und Weite,
das haben die Schweizer gesucht.
Ihr nächster Nachbar
lebt 1 km weit entfernt.
Trotzdem,
oder vielleicht gerade deswegen,
sind die beiden schnell Teil
der lokalen Gemeinschaft geworden.
Die 100 Personen,
die hier hinten im Tal und auf
den drei Höfen weiter vorn wohnen,
sind schon eine ziemliche Familie.
Jeder weiss alles über jeden
und Facebook weiss sowieso alles,
weil jeder alles dort postet.
Man kann noch so
in der Patsche sitzen -
wenn man den Nachbarn
um Hilfe bittet, kommt er.
Morgen soll nichts schiefgehen.
In 24 Std. schon soll nämlich das
erste Tiny-Haus aufgerichtet sein.
(Heinz) Gut, morgen ist es so weit.
Einige wichtige Dinge
müssen wir noch besprechen.
Wir machen es folgendermassen:
Sämi, du hängst den Container an.
Du hast ihn in Ostermundigen ja
beladen und weisst, wo alles ist.
Dann kannst du
stückweise Material rausgeben.
Steff, würdest du
Sämi im Container helfen?
Beim Ausfädeln muss man darauf
achten, dass nichts kaputtgeht.
Ihr beiden montiert und
ich achte als Schnittstelle darauf,
dass wir
die richtige Reihenfolge einhalten.
Dann packen wir es morgen an.
- Yes!
(Heinz) Go.
* Lachen *
* Sanfte Musik *
Das Brisas del Mar -
zu Deutsch: Die Meeresbrise.
Das ist Otmar Gemperlis Restaurant.
Wochenlang haben sie es umgebaut.
Morgen ist endlich die Eröffnung.
Gabors ehemalige Chefin
ist samt Freund zur Unterstützung
auf die Insel gereist.
Ich bin gespannt wie ein Regenbogen,
v.a. auf die Anzahl der Gäste.
Das nimmt mich wunder. Wir müssen
aber zuerst fertig werden.
Gut?
- Ja.
Gut. Voilà.
Hey! Bravo!
Langsam steigt die Nervosität.
Nur wenige Minuten vom Lokal entfernt
ist das Meer.
Gabor Balogh
kommt ursprünglich aus Ungarn.
Er hat schon in London
und in der Schweiz gelebt.
Es war immer mein Traum,
am Meer zu leben.
In Ungarn ist es leider nicht so ...
Dort hat man wenig Chancen,
das Meer zu sehen.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass ich das erleben werde.
An der Cala Agulla
findet er Sand für die Windlichter.
Zum Glück hat Otmar
nur einen Eimer Sand bestellt.
Hola.
- Alles gut?
* Gabor ächzt. *
Schau, meine Hand.
Rot.
Schnitzel vom Schweinerücken - das
ist der Klassiker des Restaurants.
Mariyan kocht
seit neun Jahren schon im Brisas.
Otmar ist froh,
dass er ihn behalten konnte.
Aber auch der erfahrene Koch
ist ein wenig nervös.
(Spanisch)
Alle sind im Schuss.
Besonders Gabor ist voller
Tatendrang - und dann passiert's:
* Gabor stöhnt. *
(Corinna) Zeig mal.
Gabor ist gegen
die frisch geputzte Scheibe gerannt.
Ihr habt die Aufkleber
vom Fenster entfernt.
Da waren überall Aufkleber.
- Was für Aufkleber?
Da waren Aufkleber -
"Willkommen" usw.
Die sind nicht nur da,
weil sie schön sind,
sondern weil man Aufkleber
auf den Fenstern haben muss,
damit so was nicht passiert.
Halt dir das an den Kopf.
Wir brauchen Aufkleber,
auch zum Schutz der Kinder.
So ist es gut.
- (Mann) Leg dich hin.
Ist es okay, Schatz?
- Mhm.
Corinna, sorry, aber was ist los?
Du kommst her und fährst mich an.
Nein. Es sind einfach Sachen ...
Ja, aber das kannst du
normal mit mir besprechen.
Mir fiel jetzt auf, dass ihr
die Aufkleber entfernt habt.
Ja, das ist jetzt passiert.
Ja, und jetzt hat er sich wehgetan.
Ja, aber du musst nicht
so reagieren.
Darauf habe ich keine Lust.
- Ich?
Ja.
- Du.
Hier sollten Tische stehen,
weil die Gäste hoch sitzen wollen.
Und was machst du?
Zudem ist hier eine Uhr.
Es ist Basiswissen, dass man
keine Uhr hinter der Theke hat,
um die Leute nicht daran
zu erinnern, wie spät es ist.
Du machst es trotzdem.
Ihr macht, was ihr wollt.
Das ist ja auch gut so.
Es ist euer Laden.
Das können wir doch
normal besprechen.
Ja.
- Normal.
Ja, nachdem die Leute verletzt sind.
Das habe ich alles schon gesagt.
Alright.
Der Golf von Mexiko liegt gut 10 Min.
von Tscharners neuem Daheim entfernt.
In Florida ist es Winter,
und die Nächte sind bitterkalt.
So kalt war es
während der letzten 30 Jahre nicht.
Trotz der Kälte -
ihr neues Familienmitglied,
Hund Rocky, muss raus.
Mario wollte
schon immer einen Hund haben.
Hier hat er endlich Zeit dafür.
Wir sahen Rocky
vor zwei Wochen in einem Tierheim.
Er ist wahnsinnig lieb.
Er war von der ersten Minute an
total anhänglich
und auf uns bezogen.
Er sprang in den Pick-up,
legte sich auf die Fussmatte
und schlief gleich ein -
als hätte er
schon immer zu uns gehört.
Komm, wir gehen weiter.
Einmal mehr: Auch in ihrem Traumhaus
macht die Heizung Probleme.
Nun schauen wir mal,
ob die Heizung wieder funktioniert.
Na?
In Florida
heizt man mit der Klimaanlage.
Rocky.
Uh!
* Dumpfes Brummen *
Das ist immer noch unser Sorgenkind.
Eigentlich funktioniert sie gut,
aber wenn es weniger als 3-4 °C hat,
friert der Verdampfer ein.
Dann gelangt anstatt warme Luft
kalte Luft ins Haus.
Sie schaltet sich
auch nicht selbstständig aus.
Wenn man den Zeitpunkt verpasst,
in dem es hier draussen gefriert,
wird das Haus innerhalb von 10 Min.
auf 10 °C heruntergekühlt.
Brr.
Die Nächte sind wohl kalt,
doch kaum zeigt sich die Sonne,
wird es im namhaften Sonnenstaat
schnell warm.
So, jetzt sollte es
wieder warm werden.
Okay, da bin ich froh.
- Jetzt heizt sie wieder.
Gut.
(Kind) Mama!
Ich mag Kälte nicht.
Das nervt mich.
Ich trage jeweils
mehrere Kleidungsschichten
und ziehe im Lauf des Tages
eine nach der anderen aus.
Morgen hat Lily Rose
ihren ersten Schultag.
Mit grosser Begeisterung besuchte sie
in der Schweiz die 1. Klasse.
Doch nur sieben Wochen lang,
dann ist die Familie ausgewandert.
* Lachen *
Du ... ähm ...
Hast du in der Schweiz
noch Kastanien gesammelt?- Ja.
Als Andenken.
- Du bist mir eine.
Mal sehen, ob die Kinder hier auch
einen Rucksack zur Schule mitnehmen.
Hey!- Das wissen wir noch nicht.
Wir nehmen ihn mal mit.
Hier drin hat es noch ...
Hast du wieder Blätter gesammelt?
Es muss alles perfekt sein.
Ja, ich mag das nicht,
das weisst du.
Ich glaube,
ich hole den Staubsauger.- Hm.
Okay, dann hole ihn.
Wo ist denn deine Schere?
Lily Rose steht
vor einem neuen Lebensabschnitt,
und die ganze Familie fiebert mit.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ah, Lily Rose!
Auf Island
haben die Zimmerleute ein Ziel:
Heute soll das erste Tiny-Haus
stehen.
Element für Element
verlässt den Container.
Jetzt geht es dann erst richtig los.
Dieser Moment ist einmalig.
Kaum angefangen,
und schon kommt die erste Bodenplatte
perfekt auf Steffs Fundament
zu liegen.
Du musst mir den mit dem Brett
etwas rüberschieben.
Gleichzeitig läuft der Gästebetrieb.
Es ist gleich dort oben.
Okay.
Fahrt ihr danach in Richtung
Akureyri oder nach Húsavík?
Welches ist der nächste Stopp?
- Mývatn.- Mývatn.
Ein Ehepaar hat
für eine Nacht eine Wohnung gebucht.
Jetzt ist die Hengifosslodge voll.
- Das ist euer Zimmer.
Aus 55 Bauelementen setzen
die Arbeiter ein Häuschen zusammen.
Der Bau kommt gut voran.
Wenn es weniger als 35 ist, geht es.
30 sollte gehen.
Es dürfte fast etwas grösser sein.
* Er lacht. *
Aber eigentlich reicht es.
Es gibt eine kleine Küche,
einen Aufenthaltsraum,
eine Toilette und eine Dusche -
mehr braucht man eigentlich nicht.
Oben ist die Schlafkajüte.
Die jetzigen Apartments
sind kleiner.
* Sanfte Musik *
Dänu, du bist schon zu weit drin.
Heb es nochmals etwas an.
Ein riesiges Bauprojekt auf Island.
Manchmal kann es Isabelle
kaum fassen,
wohin sie das Leben verschlagen hat.
Ich hätte mir nie erträumt,
dass ich jemals nach Island
auswandere und hier Häuser baue.
Es ist schon etwas ganz Besonderes.
Wir freuen uns wirklich.
Wir freuen uns auch, dass wir
alles termingerecht hinkriegten
und dass alles funktioniert.
Wir sind zufrieden, nicht wahr?
- Der Fahrer kommt auch.
Ja, wir haben ihn einberechnet.
- Gut.
Es versteht sich von selbst:
Die Arbeiter werden verpflegt.
Das ist aufwendig
und muss gut geplant sein.
Für uns lohnt sich das nicht.
Wir fahren 30 Min. bis
zum nächsten Lebensmittelgeschäft.
Nur wegen eines Brotes
1 Std. Fahrzeit zu haben,
lohnt sich nicht.
Daher ist es einfacher,
wenn wir es selbst backen.
Seit wir auf dieser Insel sind,
ist schuften angesagt.- Ja.
Pane, pane.
* Ruhige Musik *
Der kleine Zwischenfall auf Mallorca
hat für viel Aufregung gesorgt.
Gut, dass die Zeit fehlt,
um sich lange zu ärgern.
Kann man für morgen
schon reservieren?
Er würde gern für morgen
reservieren. - Hi.
Na, wie geht's?
- (Mann) Gut, dir auch?
Ja, mir auch. Wie viele
wollen morgen denn kommen?
15. - 15 Personen?
Wie spät wollt ihr kommen?
(Mann) 19 Uhr?
- 19 Uhr. Kriegen wir das hin?
Ja.
- Ja. Der Koch sagt Ja.
Wir sehen uns morgen. Tschüssi.
- Tschau.
Es hat eine Aussprache gegeben,
und diese wird nun
mit einem Essen gefeiert.
Sowieso: Gabor ist glücklicherweise
mit einem kleinen Schrecken
davongekommen.
Es fühlt sich
nicht mehr so geschwollen an.
Nur hier noch.
Das kann mal passieren.
Ich habe mich heute
einfach nur erschreckt.
Ich wollte keinen Arbeitsunfall
vor der Eröffnung.
Ich bekam einfach einen Schreck
und reagierte kurz
mit Unverständnis.
Aber gut.
Ja.
Wir wollen beide eigentlich
nur das Beste fürs Geschäft.
Das haben wir
mit unserem Gespräch so besiegelt.
Wir bauen das Ganze
mit allem Drum und Dran auf.
Wir haben
die persönliche Differenz geklärt.
Ja. Vielen Dank.
Morgen geht es los.
* Ruhige Musik *
Das Essen ist fertig.
Wow!
* Applaus *
Die Stimmung soll fröhlich sein.
(Mann) Wow!
Schau dir den Kartoffelsalat an!
Vielen Dank für alles. Zum Wohl.
Einen guten Start für uns morgen.
Ja. Kommt, alle miteinander.
(Alle) Ho-oi!
Zum Wohl!
* Ruhige Musik *
Auch in Florida
herrscht grosse Vorfreude.
Lily Rose muss zur Schule,
Ruby Sue, iss.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, ten ...
Endlich ist es so weit:
der erste Schultag
im grossen Amerika.
... twenty-one, twenty-three,
twenty-four, twenty-six ...
One, two ...
* Ruhige Musik *
Schon vor ihrer Auswanderung haben
sich die Eltern viel Zeit genommen,
um eine gute Schule für die Kleine
zu finden.
Es ist schon speziell,
sie hier in diesem fernen Land
zur Schule zu schicken.
Alles ist anders.
Das Schulsystem ist total anders.
Die Schulen
sind komplett anders aufgebaut.
In der Schweiz hatte es sich
schon etwas eingespielt.
Sie ging in den Kindergarten
und dann in die 1. Klasse.
Es lief eigentlich alles rund.
Hier müssen wir halt schauen,
wie es funktioniert.
Auch bei mir ist
eine leichte Anspannung vorhanden.
Sagt ihr noch tschüss?
- Mach's gut.
Lily Rose weiss:
Die ganze Familie unterstützt sie.
Das gibt Sicherheit.
Wir sehen uns später.
- Tschüss, Schatz.
Mama kommt gleich wieder.
* Sanfte Musik *
Tschüss, bis später.
- Tschüss.
Dort vorn blinkt es.
Wir fuhren so oft hier vorbei
und sagten:
"Eure Schule,
bald geht ihr dorthin."
Oh, hier ist gesperrt. Okay.
Dann müssen wir vorn rein.
"No parking", okay.
Dann parken wir woanders.
Achtung, Schätzchen.
Good morning.
Die Medart Elementary School hat die
besten Bewertungen in der Umgebung.
Morgen schon wird Lily Rose
ganz amerikanisch
mit dem Bus zur Medart fahren.
Sie lernte schon draussen
im Flur zwei Mädchen kennen,
die in ihrer Klasse sind,
und strahlte über beide Ohren.
Ich glaube, es geht ganz schnell,
bis sie neue Freundinnen findet
und sich wohlfühlt.
Ich habe gar keine Bedenken.
Und dennoch wird der Tag
in einem kleinen Drama enden.
* Sanfte Musik *
Den hier würde ich gern mitnehmen.
Das ist einer der Favoriten.
Ein Bäumchen für die Aufrichte -
aus dem eigenen Wald.
Es gibt so viele.
Es gibt zwei Varianten:
der Kleine oder der Grosse.
Aber Isa weiss,
dass bei mir alles gross sein muss.
Deshalb nehme ich den.
Jetzt fälle ich ihn.
* Sägegeräusch *
Zack.
100 ha - ein Viertel des Grundstücks
der Schweizer - ist bewaldet.
Die Tanne ist Symbol für
Standhaftigkeit und Langlebigkeit.
Es ist noch nicht Abend,
und das letzte Teil, der Dachfirst,
ist aufgesetzt.
Noch ein bisschen, nicht?
Auf der anderen Seite
ist mehr Platz.
Sehr ...
Sehr schön.
Hier hinten
machen wir es noch schräger.
Jeder Handgriff sitzt -
der Bau ist gelungen.
Du kannst dir
noch die Küche ansehen.- Ja.
Es ist schön geräumig.
Ich kann mir bereits vorstellen,
wie es eingerichtet aussieht.
Man hat genügend Platz. Hier unten
kann man noch vorbeigehen.
Wenn man so liegt,
hat man genügend Platz.
Man geht sowieso
nur zum Schlafen rauf.- Klar.
Es ist kein Aufenthaltsraum.
- Nein.
Der Tradition entsprechend
schmückt Elisabeth den Richtbaum.
Jetzt sind sogar noch Späne dran.
- Hobelspäne. Die Späne flogen.
* Hämmern *
Noch etwas mehr rüber zu Sämi.
Alles gut?
- Ja, prima.
* Applaus *
Bravo.
* Isabelle seufzt glücklich. *
Das erste Häuschen haben wir.
Schön, was?
- Mhm.
Es war eine Schufterei, was?
Am Rande des Dorfes Cala Rajada
haben die beiden Auswanderer
eine kleine Wohnung gemietet.
Meine Uhr.
Heute ist der grosse Tag:
Ohne grosses Tamtam
wollen sie ihr Restaurant,
das Brisas del Mar, eröffnen.
Du magst die Sonne auch, was?
Ich habe gut geschlafen.
Wir sind gut vorbereitet
und es sollte alles gut klappen.
Nervös bin ich zurzeit nicht,
aber vielleicht kommt das,
wenn wir ins Restaurant fahren.
Gestern Abend fiel uns ein, dass
wir kein Brot organisiert haben.
Das konnten wir
kurzfristig organisieren,
damit wir starten können.
Man muss an viele Dinge denken,
um den Betrieb hochzufahren.
Für Otmar wird nun ein Traum wahr:
ein eigenes Restaurant
auf seiner Lieblingsinsel.
Während Jahren führte er im
Luzernischen schon ein Restaurant.
Der Profi erkennt gute Mitarbeiter.
Mariyan ist einer davon.
Nur für Gabor ist alles neu.
Völlig unspektakulär
nimmt der erste Tag seinen Lauf.
Jetzt haben wir geöffnet.
Die Gäste können kommen.
Keine 5 Min. vergehen,
und schon sind die ersten Gäste da.
(Frau) Ah, okay.
* Rasante Musik *
Zweimal Cola. Bitte schön.
- Oh!
Alle sind auf Trab.
- Mariyan, die Erste.
Was?
- Die erste Bestellung.
Zwei Salate Caprese.
Vielleicht solltet
ihr euch einfach hinsetzen.
Das sorgt auch ein bisschen für ...
- Ja, ja.
Oder ihr könntet
die Passanten animieren.
Dann sieht es nach mehr Gästen aus.
- Dann hole ich mir ein Bier.
Bringst du mir ...
Ich trinke ein Cüpli oder so.
Mehr und mehr füllt sich das Lokal.
Einmal komplett öffnen.
Nicht warten.
Der Rest muss Schaum sein.
Nein, warte, warte.
Nicht nochmals öffnen.
Dann kommt nur Schaum raus.
So.
- Ja.- Super.
Er hält das Gleichgewicht
mit dem Tablett.
Am ersten Tag ist man natürlich noch
etwas unsicher, aber das ist normal.
Innerhalb von einer Woche wird er
mit dem Tablett Ballett tanzen.
Corinna führte das Brisas
während Jahren.
Nun ist es ihre letzte Saison.
Mariyan, wo muss das jetzt hin?
Nur so?
- Tapas?- Tapas.
Es ist ein bisschen stressig,
weil ich nicht weiss, wo was ist.
Ich sehe nach.
- Tisch 9, bitte.
Tisch 9. Tisch 9.
Tisch 9.
Soll ich helfen?
- Ja, Brot habe ich.
Alles hier hinstellen,
oder wisst ihr, was ihr nehmt?
(Frau) Wir tauschen.
- (Mann) Herrlich.
Guten Appetit.
- Danke schön.
* Rasante Musik *
Endlich Zeit für eine kurze Pause.
* Er seufzt erleichtert. *
Als ich das Tablett hielt,
hat meine Hand gezittert.
Ich sagte zu den Gästen:
"Entschuldigung,
das ist mein erster Tag."
Dann hatten alle Verständnis.
Das war kein Problem.
* Ruhige, mediterrane Klänge *
Gegen Abend
sind auch die Stammgäste da.
Wer hat die Spaghetti?
Darf ich es rüberreichen?
Wow!
* Ruhige, mediterrane Klänge *
Wir sind mittags
sehr chaotisch gestartet.
Es war ein Wirrwarr
und jeder machte irgendwas,
aber es funktionierte irgendwie.
Es gab halt
keine wirkliche Schulung,
v.a. für Gabor,
aber auch für mich nicht.
Mit dem Kassensystem und mit den
Getränken hatten wir noch keine ...
Wir wussten noch nicht genau,
wo alles ist.
Das verursachte ein gewisses Chaos.
Aber jetzt hat es sich beruhigt.
Gabor weiss
schon viel über den Ablauf
und wir haben
bereits vieles optimiert.
Es ist eine gemütliche Stimmung.
Otmar ist sichtlich entspannt.
Die Eröffnung ist geglückt.
Im Mobile Home in Alligator Point
wird heftig gearbeitet.
Nur Ruby Sue
ist für einmal gelangweilt.
Die Schwester hat heute einen
grossen Schritt in die Welt gemacht.
Sie aber muss bei den Eltern bleiben.
Abrisstag!
- Ja, Abrisstag.
Schau, es ist nur aufgeklebt.
Mama!
- Nein, Rocky.
Immobilien kaufen, renovieren,
vermieten oder gar weiterverkaufen -
das ist Melanie
und Marios Geschäftsmodell.
Das Mobile Home
ist ihr erstes Objekt,
das sie bald schon vermieten wollen.
Hier muss ich noch fertig streichen
und dann die Wandfliesen verlegen.
Das ist immer meine Aufgabe.
No problem, nicht wahr?
Die ist noch schön.
- Die ist noch in Ordnung.
Die ist neu.
Dann schmeisse ich das
in den Container.- Ja.
Die beiden sind handwerklich begabt,
machen am liebsten alles selbst.
Hier habe ich
im Frühling die Fliesen verlegt,
aber die Silikonfugen
sind uns gar nicht gut gelungen.
Wir müssen sie entfernen
und erneut anbringen.
Wir lernen jedes Mal dazu.
Uh! Herrgott nochmal,
ist das rutschig.
Nur: Viel Zeit bleibt ihnen nicht,
denn alle, die ganze Familie,
wollen dabei sein,
wenn Lily Rose Schulschluss hat.
* Rasante Musik *
Wenn die Schule aus ist,
werden die Kinder eins ums andere
dort vorn abgeholt.
Als sie noch nicht zur Schule ging,
beobachteten wir das bereits
und ich sagte: "Ich stehe nie in
dieser Schlange und warte auf dich."
* Ruhige Musik *
Hallo.
Wie war's?
- Gut.
War es schön? Hat es dir gefallen?
* Sanfte Musik *
Hallo.
- Wie geht's, Lily?
Wie geht's, Lily?
- Ja, hallo, Schätzchen.
Wie war's?
- Gut.
Sind ganz viele Kinder
in eurer Klasse?
Ja, aber mehr Mädchen als Jungs.
- Ja, ich weiss.
Ein aufregender Tag. Doch die grosse
Überraschung kommt erst noch.
* Sanfte Musik *
Schinken, Speck, Zwiebeln ...
Steff war Truppenkoch im Militär.
Er weiss,
wie man hungrige Männer verpflegt.
Das Kochbuch der Schweizer Armee
hat er auf Mann.
Für Isabelle
ist es eine neue Erfahrung.
Ich bin es mir gar nicht gewohnt,
für so viele Leute zu kochen.
Das ist schon
eine Herausforderung für mich.
Wenn man wie ich kein Topkoch ist,
ist das schon ...
Man will seine Sache gut machen,
damit genug da ist
und es obendrein noch schmeckt.
Die Fahrt bis zum nächsten Supermarkt
in Egilsstadir dauert gut 30 Min.
Die Tage der Auswanderer sind
während der Bauarbeiten eng getaktet.
* Sanfte Musik *
Für einmal hilft Steff
nicht beim Bau mit.
Er bereitet die Ferienwohnung
für die nächsten Gäste vor.
Ich habe nicht so viel Zeit.
Wenn ich solche Dinge mache,
muss das zackig gehen.
Das ist Serienarbeit
und läuft wie in einer Fabrik.
Aber ich mache das ziemlich gern.
So kann ich Isa unterstützen.
So.
Jetzt muss ich es noch heil
um den Pfeiler da vorn schaffen.
Dann ist es okay.
Hilfst du mir kurz?
Ich mache hinten die Tür auf.
- Ja.
Drei Schubkarren voll mit Essen
haben die beiden Frauen gekauft.
So.
- Du kannst nicht reinfahren.
Nein, das tue ich nicht.
* Lachen *
Das ist noch nicht alles.
Obwohl Steff
die Einsamkeit in Island gesucht hat,
mag er es eigentlich auch,
wenn etwas läuft.
Der Eventmanager hatte jahrelang
während der Freizeit Gäste verwöhnt.
Hüttenfeeling ist immer schön.
Ich führte ja das Paradiesli ...
... im Glarnerland.
Dort betreute ich übers Wochenende
bis zu sieben Gäste.
Wir gingen Schneeschuhlaufen,
ich kochte für sie
und organisierte Partys usw.
Mir machte es immer grossen Spass,
wenn Gäste da waren.
Ich koche auch gern für Gäste.
Das ist für mich
wirklich kein Problem,
aber zu bauen,
zu arbeiten, zu putzen
und nebst den Arbeitern
noch richtige Gäste zu haben,
ist schon relativ viel.
So, das Wichtigste ist drin.
Langweilig
wird es ihm bestimmt nicht.
Sobald die Arbeiter abreisen, müssen
sie mit dem Innenausbau loslegen.
Auf Mallorca beginnt nun der Alltag.
Otmars neuer Arbeitsweg:
Gerade mal 10 Min. rollend unter der
spanischen Sonne, und das im März.
Die Eröffnung
war auch finanziell ein Erfolg.
Corinna und ich machten um etwa
0.30 Uhr gemeinsam den Abschluss.
Wir haben
knapp 2'000 Euro Umsatz gemacht.
Am ersten Tag.
Die zwei Frauen,
die gestern hier waren, sagten:
"Wir möchten nicht nach Hause gehen.
Es ist so schön."
Darf ich dir etwas empfehlen?
Ich würde es so machen, damit
die Leute noch vorbeigehen können.
Ihr Restaurant haben sie
schon früh im Jahr eröffnet.
Nach all den Auslagen
brauchen sie endlich Einnahmen.
Jetzt ist es gut.
Guten Morgen.
- Morgen.
Für Adina
beginnt die siebte Saison im Brisas.
Die gestandene Kellnerin
gibt Otmar Sicherheit.
Hallo.
- Wo ist meine Lehrmutter?
Doch am zweiten Tag bleibt es ruhig,
sehr ruhig.
Das heisst gar nichts.
Die Leute sind bei dem schönen
Wetter ... Heute ist Markttag.
Die Leute gehen runter ins Dorf.
Auf dem Rückweg essen sie hier
zu Mittag oder trinken einen Kaffee.
Ab dann geht es erst los. Das ist
samstags vor der Saison so üblich.
Es geht eigentlich erst Ende April,
Anfang Mai so richtig los.
Dann kommen die grossen Gruppen.
Dann sind viele Urlauber da.
Das erfahrene Personal
nimmt es gelassen.
Diese Ruhe hat Otmar,
der neu auf der Insel ist, nicht.
Ich hoffe, das bleibt nicht so.
Ich hoffe, dass sich das Restaurant
bald wieder füllt
und dass wir
viele zufriedene Gäste haben.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Doch so richtig will sich das Brisas
am Tag nach der Eröffnung
nicht füllen.
Hallo.
- (Mann) Hola, buenas.
Ein ereignisreicher Tag
geht in Florida zu Ende.
Mit grosser Begeisterung
ist Lily Rose in ihr Abenteuer
Schülerin einer amerikanischen
Elementary School gestartet.
Doch bei den Hausaufgaben
hat sie grosse Mühe im Rechnen.
In der Schulmappe
finden die Eltern den Grund dafür.
Oh!
Sie ist in der 2. Klasse
anstatt in der 1. Klasse.
Okay.
Hm!
Deshalb ist es ...
Wir müssen
mit der Schulleiterin reden.
Das müssen wir besprechen.
Ich weiss nicht,
weshalb sie in die 2. Klasse kam.
Wenn ich mir
diese Hausaufgaben ansehe ...
Ja, das ist nicht so einfach.
- Das finde ich etwas tricky.
Wie viele Monate
war sie in der 1. Klasse?
Zwei Monate.
Den Rest des Augusts und den Sept...
Sieben Wochen lang
war sie in der 1. Klasse.
Wenn ich mir diese Rechenaufgaben
anschaue, weiss ich nicht,
ob es eine gute Idee war, dass
sie gleich in die 2. Klasse kam.
Mal sehen.
Ist das die einzige Hausaufgabe?
- Ja.
Die Kleine
ist in der falschen Klasse.
* Lily Rose beginnt zu weinen. *
Für Lily Rose
bricht eine Welt zusammen.
* Lily Rose weint
und spricht unverständlich. *
Nicht, Lily.
Es ist alles gut.
Ich glaube, wir lassen das,
das ist viel zu viel verlangt.
Das ist wirklich
viel zu viel verlangt.
Wir müssen morgen mit ihnen reden.
* Schluchzen *
* Melancholische Klänge *
Schatzi.
- Sei nicht traurig.
Es ist wirklich nicht deine Schuld.
Das darfst du nicht denken.
Sie setzten sich hin
und lösten die Aufgabe gleich.
Extrem schnell und gut.
Schatzi, das musst du nicht können.
Glaubst du mir das?
Das musst du
in deinem Alter nicht können.
Wir rufen morgen
vor der Schule kurz an.
Und in der nächsten Folge
von "Auf und davon" ...
Oh, der Schulbus!
... überstürzen sich die Ereignisse:
Bye-bye.
- Bye-bye.
Lily Rose
darf endlich Schulbus fahren.
In welche Klasse
wird sie wohl eingeteilt?
Und Tscharners expandieren.
Ihr neuestes Objekt:
ein Apartment direkt am Meer.
Melanie
treibt ihr eigenes Business voran:
Hochzeiten am Strand ausrichten.
Auf Mallorca
nimmt die Saison langsam Fahrt auf.
Nur: Gabor ist allein.
Otmar hat eine heftige Krise
und ist in die Schweiz zurück.
Man hat keine Energie,
um irgendwas zu bewältigen.
Für Gabor eine schwierige Situation.
Ich vermisse ihn sehr.
Wir waren in diesen acht Jahren
immer zusammen.
Auf Island
wird weiter hart gearbeitet.
Die Möbel für die Tiny-Häuser
sind da.
Muskelkater haben wir schon lange
nicht mehr. Wir sind stark geworden.
Und mit dem Schnee fängt
für die beiden die Badesaison an.
Das ist Island.
# U sie stige i Flüger, flüge
mit de Vögu furt, chöme nüm meh hei.
# U sie löh hie aues zrugg,
uf de Suechi für nes neus Dahei.
# Sie göh hüt no uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2024
# Uf u dervo, yeah.